[Music]
hello and welcome to DevOps test
automation today we will see what test
automation is and where test automation
fits into the overall DevOps automation
continuous integration continuous
delivery we will also see various test
automation frameworks that are available
in DevOps we do talk about a lot of
automation using a lot of tools to
automate the non human steps that are
part of your entire SDLC lifecycle
automation can be achieved using various
tools at different steps of your
software development and delivery like
to create your build to trigger your
test cases to deploy your build to run
various other automation scripts build
tools like maven ant can help automate
your build creation you can use tools
like puppet and ansible that can
automate the configuration management
for your entire environment set up
continuous integration tools like
Jenkins and teamcity can automate
various steps of your delivery pipeline
execution then there are tools like
octopus deploy and kubernetes that can
automate the code deployment steps of
your continuous deployment lastly you
have continuous monitoring tools like
Nagios to automate the server monitoring
in other words monitoring the different
applications you have running on your
server let's look at what DevOps test
automation is similarly where all the
steps of your software development and
delivery process can be automated the
testing that comes at the different
stages of your software development like
your unit testing your integration
testing performance testing stress
testing penetration testing can also be
automated these tests are done at
different stages of your software
development project and test automation
also includes continuous quality tools
that help manage and maintain the code
quality aspects of software development
tools that help you automatically check
the code coverage of your software code
and do automated code reviews for your
software code the importance of software
testing and quality control cannot be
stressed upon enough in an
sdlc process when the underlying code
written does not meet certain code
quality criteria all the tools that you
use for automation from your coding
stage onward to your deployment stage
could become a huge maintenance
nightmare very quickly because you'll be
struggling to correct your code to fix
your code and automatically run the
tools that help you do an automated
build automated testing automated
deployment because these tools are like
triggers and once you run the trigger if
the underlying code does not meet a
certain quality criteria your automated
code your automated steps are still
going to run every time and
unfortunately fail or raise a lot of
unnecessary issues because your
underlying code doesn't meet a certain
quality criteria and very soon you could
be caught up in maintaining your
automated pipeline and also trying to
maintain and fix your code issues and
things can get out of hand very quickly
automated process workflow is a series
or set of interconnected steps that run
in a particular order to achieve the
desired end results if made run on a
less than desirable quality code the
automated workflow will keep pushing the
same code quality into the production
environment or worse fail at each and
every step of your automation workflow
requiring someone in the team to
manually monitor the automated workflow
thus completely negating the purpose of
automation in the first place there are
different testing frameworks available
in the market for various technologies
that can be used at the different stages
of the sdlc process these frameworks
allow you to write scripts or test
scripts that can be written for every
use case that you are deploying every
functionality that you are writing the
code for that has to be implemented in
your software project there are
frameworks and tools that can automate
all the test steps of your entire
software project these are some of the
test automation frameworks available for
unit testing ASP unit for unit testing
of ASP based web sites and pages API
sanity checker for a unit test generator
for C C++ libraries
can also automatically generate
reasonable input data for every API
function SI unit for OS independent
Windows Linux Mac OS X and probably
others cpp unit for c++ set by designed
to keep usage easy and allow it to work
on embedded platforms c++ is buried in
macros so the learning curve for a c
programmer is minimal on this and it is
ported to Symbian and has a mocking
support library CPP you Mach X unit
supports running tests concurrently
macros are only used for test setup not
for test assertions X unit for testing
native XML programs individual XSLT
templates and Java programs that equal
XML data HTML unit for Java hit list
browser emulators J unit for Java based
project unit testing test ng can include
unit tests functional tests integration
tests and can create even non-functional
tests like your load test time tests
unit testing framework for JavaScript
and node.js
it works with any unit testing framework
and assertion libraries Visual Studio is
the unit testing framework that was
first included in visual studio team
system in 2005 when it integrated with
the ID but was not available in the most
used standard edition from Visual Studio
2008 it is also available in the
professional Edition starting with
Visual Studio Express 2013 it is
included with Visual Studio Express
editions PHP unit it produces XML HTML
reports with code coverage PI tests
distributed testing tool for Python a
sequel unit for sequel statements and
queries and Spock is a testing and
specification framework for Java and
groovy applications
Spock supports specifications by example
and BDD style testing as well then you
have various system integration
frameworks like your test ng the
can include unit test functional test
integration test your Jasmine which is a
bdd framework independent easily
integration with the Ruby projects and
continuous builds allows for both Dom
less testing and a synchronous testing
you have Jas testimony that runs
JavaScript tests the goal of the J estás
- be able to test javascript code using
an approach that test-driven programmers
will feel comfortable with particularly
in the context of continuous integration
then you have quality gate one studio
which is a commercial freeware test
framework for United integration testing
that analyzes dependencies between test
cases to flow that data between them
it supports combinational testing
multi-threading and time dependencies
you have T sequel LT which includes
mocking frameworks continuous
integration support and uses sequel
tests sui you have juk C a library for
unit testing SLT style sheets for Java
mo X unit works for both MATLAB and
octave and uses all style
object-oriented programming features and
is compatible with MATLAB X unit test
framework you can also be used with
Travis CI and shippable continuous
integration services and integrates with
mokhov to provide code coverage reports
either offline or through coveralls dot
al and mate is n unit and part cover
code generation and integration add-in
for Microsoft Visual Studio 2005 2008
then you have a few BDD frameworks
behavior driven testing Lib C BDD is
block based behavior driven development
library that allows for very readable
tests tests are written inside main
functions and this allows for great
flexibility on how to run these tests
you have C green which is unit testing
framework including strict and loose
mocks reflective run or discovering
tests automatically
Suites BDD style
except under test notation test
protected against exceptions natural
language out and extensible reporter
learning mocks then you have catch which
is header only no external dependencies
auto registration TDD and BDD features
you have igloo which is BDD style unit
testing in C++ easy be BDD testing in
groovy
Spock BDD with built-in mocking and spy
capabilities H spec which is r-spec
style bdd framework for a Haskell that
integrates with quick check and H unit
you have J spec which is highly readable
BDD fifty-plus matchers Dom framework
independent they sync Rhino nodejs
support and more you have chai which is
BDD slash TDD assertion library for node
and the browser that can be delightfully
paired with any JavaScript testing
framework bustard is which is bt d /x
unit assertion expectation browser slash
server extendable with tools like
linting and other QA measures highly
configurable well-documented and
actively adopted a PHP spec which is a
BDD style testing framework scalar test
which is scalable test framework
supports different styles of testing TDD
BDD and more and you have expec and the
behavior driven development framework
for xslt and xquery and is based on the
spec framework of our spec which is a
bdd framework for Ruby these are a few
mocking frameworks that can be used for
different kinds of testings you have C
green which allows you to do unit
testing framework including strict and
loose mocks reflective Runner
discovering tests automatically Suites
BDD style concept under test notation
test protection against concepts natural
language out extensible reporter and
learning mocks you have C market which
is a test framework for C which support
for mock objects it's easy
use and setup see maka is a successor of
C mockery which was developed by Google
where it has been unmaintained for quite
some time so C maka was forked and will
be maintained in the future then you
have op Mach which is stubbing and
mocking framework for C and C++ based on
code generation from headers it can
check call parameters call sequence and
handle multiple inflammations of amok
and much more includes as well a small
unit testing framework with J unit
compatible XML output but works also
with any unit testing framework then you
have CXS tests uses a C++ parser and
code generator of course it requires
Python for testing registration and has
a framework for generating mocks of
global functions but not for generating
mocks of objects header only mock object
library and Eclipse plug-in to create
test doubles in a simple yet powerful
way it leverages the new C++ 11 language
facilities while still being compatible
with the C++ o 3 and has a built-in
support for cute easy mock is a mock
framework for Java J mock is a mock
framework for Java J market is an open
source framework tests can be easily
written that will mock final class
static methods constructors and so on
there are no limitations mockito is a
mock framework power mock is an
extension to both makoto and easy mock
that allows mocking of static methods
constructors final classes and methods
provides private methods removal of
static initializers then you have
enhanced PHP which is unit testing
framework with mocks and stubs built in
it runs in the command line or gets
html5 tap or XML output via a web
browser then we have a few continuous
testing tools appium is a freely
distributed open source mobile
application UI testing framework that
allows hybrid native and web
app testing it also supports automation
testing on physical servers emulators
and simulators a big advantage that
appium offers is cross-platform app
testing by using the single API for both
Android and iOS platform test scripts
because appium uses vendor provided
automation frameworks there is no need
to additionally compile any appium
authored by the code framework as you
are testing the app that is being
shipped bamboo is a continuous
integration server from Atlas
the makers of JIRA confluence and cloud
bamboo ties automated tests automated
builds and releases in a single workflow
and this helps in implementing
continuous integration deployment and
delivery all within bamboo bamboo can
help run tests in parallel batches as it
supports up to 100 remote build agents
and this helps to keep the queue flowing
and to provide quick feedback to
developers cruise control is a Java
based framework that helps implement a
continuous build process and allowing
performing a continuous integration of
software development process cruise
control net however comprises of two
executable components CC service exe
which is the window service and CC net
dot exe which is a console app included
for testing purposes as it is easier to
debug a console application rather than
a service it is recommended to perform
initial tests with CC net exe and then
to read the console output to understand
the CC net exception and behavior then
you have cucumber which is behavior
driven development is a practice that
tests systems rather than test code now
cucumber is a groovy based test tool for
bdd framework and is used to write and
run automated acceptance tests in simple
plain English that can be understood by
your business analysts by developers and
by testers while git is version control
system github is a staging platform
let's developers edit and build upon
each other's codes share prototypes and
collaborate on projects by sending a
link to github clients can test drive
the website in progress for
functionality test rail a web-based test
case management software then integrated
with github can provide developers
testers and team leads to centrally
manage and coordinate software testing
efforts Jenkins is an extensive
automation server is a continuous
integration server that automatically
involves creating and testing and
continuous delivery application that can
distribute build test loads to multiple
computers with different operating
systems this speeds up the integration
process and the users can get a fresh
build as required Jenkins also helps in
continuous delivery of applications by
guiding the definition of build pipeline
and integrating with the large number of
technologies related to testing and
deployment Jenkins can be used as a
simple CI server to build and test
Android apps to support the get version
control system and to provide unit
testing for other technologies using a
host of plugins J unit is a simple unit
and regression testing framework used by
Java developers to write readable tests
that increase programming speed and
improve the quality of code J unit test
framework can be easily integrated with
eclipse and/or maven and provides
features such as your fixtures test
Suites J unit classes and test runners J
unit has played a critical role in the
development of test-driven development
and it belongs to the family of unit
testing frameworks collectively called a
as X unit which was originated with as
sunnat maven is a tool for automating
build life cycles using Java c-sharp
Ruby scale ax and other languages
automation ensures that for building a
project only a small set of commands
need to be executed maven uses in an XML
file to explain the software project
that is being built along with its
dependencies on required
against external and components the
Apache Software Foundation hosts the
Maven project selenium automation
framework is a customized open-source
portable software testing framework for
web applications that has been developed
using selenium by using a script list
test automation framework selenium
reduces coding efforts test cycle times
and related costs which improves the
test automation efficiency of apps
developed on dotnet Ajax or Java j2ee
selenium was developed by a team of
developers and testers at ThoughtWorks
it was released under the Apache 200
licence and can be downloaded and used
without charge selenium IDE is a
full-fledged integrated development
environment for authoring tests and
using a test domain-specific language to
write tests in a number of popular
programming languages like Java c-sharp
groovy perl PHP Python and Ruby it also
is a record playback tool for authoring
tests tests ng is a testing framework
that has been designed to cover multiple
test categories such as end-to-end
functionality integration and unit tests
taking inspiration from J unit and n
unit tests ng has been built to provide
some additional advanced new
functionalities to the testing framework
these advanced functionalities provide a
lot of benefits to both developers and
testers to be used properly test ng
requires JDK 5 or higher installed on
the machine sonarqube provides the
capability to not only show the health
of an application but also to highlight
issues in newly introduced with equality
gate in place so you can fix the leak
and therefore improve quality
systematically
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here